[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend schön dass
sie dabei sind wie auch norbert könig
für den sport hallo und genommen und da
sind einige unsere themen
letzte bundestags debatte vor der wahl
die kanzler kandidaten und die
kandidatin versuchen auf großer bühne
noch mal zu punkten
pflicht zur auskunft mitarbeiter in
kitas schulen oder pflegeheimen müssen
künftig offenlegen ob sie gegen korona
geimpft sind
und mobilität der zukunft bei der iaa in
münchen geht es nicht mehr nur ums auto
sondern auch ums klima
diese letzte bundestags debatte vor der
wahl hatte es in sich geboten wurde eine
fast vierstündige wahlkampfshow alle
drei kandidierenden fürs kanzleramt
attackierten einander und selbst die
kanzlerin mischte sich mit ein was sie
bislang weitgehend vermieden hatte aus
berlin ist ramms eine generaldebatte zur
situation in deutschland ihr wohl
letzter auftritt vor dem bundestag ein
wehmütiger blick auf ihre amtszeit
kanzlerin merkel im wahlkampfmodus
ungewohnt deutlich setzt sie sich für
den kandidaten der union ein und warnt
vor einem linksbündnis entweder eine
regierung die mit spd und grünen die
unterstützung der linkspartei in kauf
nimmt zumindest sie nicht ausschließt
oder
sagt sag ja nur die wahrheit oder eines
und
cs und armin laschet als bundesrichter
geführte bundesregierung eine
bundesregierung die müssen maß und mitte
unser land in die zukunft
[Applaus]
merkel macht wahlkampf protest im
plenarsaal kandidat olaf scholz ihren
vizekanzler kritisiert sie scharf hatte
der doch geimpfte ironisch als
versuchskaninchen bezeichnet scholz will
weiter fürs impfen werden aber mit humor
wir müssen dafür sorge tragen dass wir
sie überzeugen indem wir das machen
lockergelassen auch mit witzen über die
auf vielen veranstaltungen gelacht wird
wenn einige nicht lachen wollen und
darüber sich aufregen hat das vielleicht
etwas damit zu tun dass sie beim blick
auf ihre umfragewerte wenig zu lachen
haben die spd selbstbewusst angesichts
schlechter umfragewerte für die union
deren kandidat armin laschet warnt vor
einem linksruck auch einer spd die sich
nach links wendet sehr verehrter herr
scholz man kann nicht mit der raute
durch die gegend laufen und reden die
saskia esken das passt einfach nicht
zusammen
wenn sie nicht mehr den kanzler vor sich
haben der auf sie achtet dann werden sie
wieder schulden machen und dann werden
sie wieder steuern die kandidatin der
grünen grenzt sich ab gegen die spd vor
allem aber gegen cdu und fdp jetzt sei
die zeit für klimaschutz
[Applaus]
das soll mal der markt regelt die
klimakrise die regel kein markt weil dem
markt sind menschen herzlich egal
für die afg ist es ein tag der
abrechnung mit großer koalition und
kanzlerin merkel ihre letzte amtszeit
von merkel war für deutschland eine
periode des beschleunigten abstiegs
ihrem nachfolger wird ein sanierungsfall
hinterlassen ein land das verunsichert
und gespalten ist koalitions planspiele
bei den oppositionsparteien die auf
einen platz in der neuen regierung
hoffen die fdp formuliert ihre
forderungen an rot und grün bei einer
ampel mitzumachen nach einer solchen
wirtschaftskrise wollen sie allen
ernstes einen aufschwung mit
steuererhöhungen organisieren ich sage
ihnen das glatte gegenteil wäre richtig
auf eine wirtschaftskrise antwortet man
mit entlastungen die linkspartei
wiederum bietet sich erneut an für rot
grün rot ich will zum schluss gerne dem
satz von christian lindner abgewandelt
wiederholen es ist besser gibt mit der
linken zu regieren als falsch mit linda
zu regieren der bundestag heute eine
wahlkampfarena in 19 tagen wird gewählt
für sie war es hier wohl ihr letzter
auftritt als gewählte kanzlerin
der bundestag hatte heute außerdem über
eine ganze reihe von gesetzentwürfen zu
entscheiden allen voran über die hilfe
für die opfer der flutkatastrophe
bund und länder geben bis zu 30
milliarden euro für die
hochwassergebiete im westen deutschlands
bestimmt ist das geld für geschädigte
privathaushalte und unternehmen und für
den wiederaufbau der infrastruktur
außerdem sollen für flutopfer eine
zeitlang mildere regeln bei insolvenz
oder pfändung gelten
auch die korona lage war thema im
bundestag da soll sich der fokus stärker
auf die lage in den kliniken richten in
zukunft soll nicht mehr nur die sieben
tage inzidenz der neu infektionen
entscheidend sein die es heute leicht
auf 83,8 gesunken wichtiger sind künftig
die krankenhauseinweisungen
diese hospitalisierung rate liegt laut
rk aktuell bei 1,69 das heißt je 100.000
einwohner wurden innerhalb einer woche
durchschnittlich
1,69 corona patienten neu in kliniken
aufgenommen wo genau der kritische
schwellenwert liegt entscheidet jedes
bundesland selbst im land berlin zum
beispiel springt die ampel bei einem
wert von 4 auf gelb bei 8 auf rot
noch eine entscheidung des parlaments
beschäftigte in kitas schulen alten oder
pflegeheimen müssen ihrem arbeitgeber
offenlegen ob sie geimpft sind und zwar
solange die sogenannte epidemische lage
von nationaler tragweite anhält also
erstmal bis zum 24 november kündigungen
oder andere arbeitsrechtliche
konsequenzen drohen nicht was die
beschäftigten davon halten zeigt malin
ihlau
pflegerin nadine troitzsch ist geimpft
sie hat auch kein problem damit dass
offen hier in ihrem arbeitsplatz im awo
pflegeheim in braunschweig zu
kommunizieren doch die stimmung unter
ihren kollegen ist gespalten es gibt
ganz viele die sagen es geht da kann was
anderes ich habe meinem arbeitgeber
österreich vorgelegt ich habe dadurch im
vorteil
wenn privatleben finde ich sonst schon
ein bisschen angst im restaurant oder so
hat es kein was anzugehen für viele
heimbewohner scheint es eine
erleichterung zu sein wenn sie wissen
wie der impfstatus der menschen ist die
ihnen so nahe kommen da fühle ich mich
an sich sicher ich mich das ganz lieb
bin ich weiß die sind geimpft wurden die
1 dies läge die offenlegung des
impfstatus gerade um die ältesten zu
schützen das sei grundsätzlich richtig
findet heimleiterin katja maria starosta
auf eine pflegekraft zu verzichten weil
sie ungeimpft ist das kommt für sie
nicht in frage wir diskutieren schon
seit mehreren jahren über pflegekraft
mangel und wir haben keine pflegekräfte
und wenn wir jetzt die ungeimpften auch
noch in die ecke stellen weil sie nicht
mehr in der pflege arbeiten dann haben
wir ein richtiges problem wer die
spritze ablehnt dem drohen keine
arbeitsrechtlichen konsequenzen doch
gewerkschaften kritisieren dass zu viel
druck ausgeübt wird muss freiwillig
bleiben und wir wehren uns dagegen dass
über den jetzigen weg eine pflicht durch
die hintertür für bestimmte
beschäftigtengruppen eingeführt wird
heimleiterin starosta kennt den
impfstatus all ihrer mitarbeiter hier
wird offen geredet doch die debatte über
den umgang mit geimpften und ungeimpften
in der arbeitswelt nimmt gerade erst
fahrt auf
jedes grundschulkind das ab 2026
eingeschult wird hat anspruch auf eine
ganztagsbetreuung auch das hat der
bundestag heute beschlossen es ist das
letzte große projekt der scheidenden
großen koalition die vierjährige
betreuung soll berufstätige eltern
entlasten und die bildungschancen der
kinder verbessern zustimmen muss noch
der bundesrat
schulen sollten sichere orte für kinder
sein das eigene zuhause erst recht doch
ausgerechnet dort finden die meisten
fälle von sexuellem missbrauch stadt
täter sind vor allem die eigenen väter
das zeigt eine studie der kommission zur
aufarbeitung sexuellen missbrauchs fast
900 betroffene wurden befragt und
erzählten auch wie schwer es als kind
ist zu entkommen henriette de maizière
noch immer ist es ein gefühl von scham
welches brigitte schmid rawicz befällt
wenn sie an das geschehene denkt was
genau passiert ist die sexuelle gewalt
die sie in ihrer unmittelbaren familie
erleiden musste hat sie als kind kaum
verstanden ich kannte ja nur dieses
lebensgefühl und das war meine realität
ich wusste ja nicht wie ist es wenn es
normal ist wenn es gut ist die
übergriffe beginnen da ist sie noch
nicht einmal in der schule ein paar mal
bittet sie um hilfe doch als kind die
vorstellung wenn die familie gesprengt
werden würde was wäre dann ja wäre es
vielleicht schlimmer als alles andere
was stattfindet eine heute in berlin
vorgestellte studie der kommission zur
aufarbeitung sexuellen missbrauchs
schaut sich den tatort familie genau an
aus den berichten ihrer die sich an die
kommission wandten die erschreckende
erkenntnis in rund 48 prozent sind die
täter väter stief und pflege väter in
rund zehn prozent sind es mütter stief
und pflegemütter
viele betroffene berichten davon dass
sie sich jemandem anvertraut haben und
hilfe gesucht haben und dann häufig die
reaktion erhalten haben dass ihnen
entweder nicht geglaubt wurde oder sie
erlebt haben dass man sich in die
privatsphäre familie nicht einmischen
heute brigitte schmid davis hat
schließlich bei ihrer mutter hilfe
gefunden was bleibt so sagt sie ist eine
trauer um die verlorene leichtigkeit
ihrer kindheit
die polnische regierung gerät wegen
ihrer umstrittenen justizreform immer
mehr unter druck jetzt hat die eu
kommission finanzielle sanktionen gegen
das land beantragt sie kritisiert in
polen würden immer noch richter und
staatsanwälte wegen unliebsamer
entscheidungen bestraft über finanzielle
sanktionen muss nun der europäische
gerichtshof entscheiden
die radikal islamischen taliban in kabul
haben mit einigen tagen verzögerung
angekündigt wer die übergangsregierung
führen soll es ist der als gemäßigt
geltende mullah mohammed hassan nach und
und innenminister ist ein von den usa
gesuchte terrorist er soll für
selbstmordattentate verantwortlich sein
in der hauptstadt reißen die proteste
nicht ab hunderte menschen gingen auf
die straße um gegen die neuen machthaber
zu demonstrieren ihr unmut richtet sich
auch gegen das nachbarland pakistan dass
die taliban maßgeblich unterstützt
brasilien feiert heute seinen
unabhängigkeitstag nicht mit einer
großen feier sondern mit landesweiten
demonstrationen der präsident selbst
trage bolz onavo hat dazu aufgerufen ein
jahr vor der wahl sind seine
umfragewerte im keller in der kritik
steht sein laxer umgang mit der pandemie
armut und eine hohe arbeitslosigkeit
zudem laufen ermittlungen gegen ihn
heute will boll szenario beweisen dass
brasilien hinter ihm steht die
gegendemonstranten sehen das anders aus
brasilia christoph röck
grün gelb so weit das auge reicht in der
hauptstadt brasilia zum nationalfeiertag
hat präsident ball szenario seine
anhänger aufgerufen für ihn zu
demonstrieren
der erklärte feind ist der oberste
gerichtshof der gegen boll szenario
wegen des verdachts mehrerer vergehen im
amt ermittelt
heute diese woche diesen monat dieses
jahr müssen wir den obersten gerichtshof
absetzen die anderen mächte beschneiden
seine macht deshalb ist es heute so
schwierig für ihn zu regieren und zu tun
was er tun möchte dass der amtierende
präsident für sich selbst demonstrieren
das zeigt wie sehr er unter druck steht
verheerende corona bilanz
wirtschaftskrise und korruptionsvorwürfe
gefährden seine macht doch mal szenario
setzt auf angriff vor seinen anhängern
droht er offen dem obersten gerichtshof
entweder der chef dieser institution
hält sich an die regeln oder es wird
etwas mit dieser institution passieren
dass wir alle nicht wollen
die beobachter alami er sagt ganz klar
das problem brasiliens heute ist dass
die institutionen den präsidenten nicht
regieren lassen das ist eindeutig eine
antidemokratische haltung
[Applaus]
fragen are so unbeliebt wie nie zuvor
gleichzeitig werden seine verbalen
angriffe auf die demokratischen
institutionen immer lauter für seine
kritiker ein zeichen der verzweiflung
aber auch der wachsenden gefahr für die
brasilianische demokratie dazu gehört
auch das polster euro seit monaten und
ohne jeden beweis zweifel sät am
elektronischen wahlsystem brasiliens im
nächsten jahr wird gewählt und die
opposition die heute ebenfalls in
mehreren städten gegen den präsidenten
demonstriert wird immer größer
die iaa in frankfurt am main war lange
eine der größten automesse der welt
jetzt präsentiert sie sich an neuem
standort mit neuem namen und neuer
ausrichtung als
mobility findet sie erstmals in münchen
statt und will weg vom ps image hin zur
umweltschutz und e-mobilität reine
augenwischerei sagen kritiker peter
meyer und alexander pohl über den
eröffnungstag
alles soll grüner werden weniger ps
dafür mehr pedale präsentiert werden die
autos verbrenner müssen fast alle
draußen bleiben eine messe zum
ausprobieren die sich über die ganze
stadt gesteckt angela merkel lobt die
bestrebungen der deutschen hersteller
diese versprechen die gesteckten
klimaziele zu erreichen
elektromobilität ist klar beschrieben
wir werden die klimaneutralität schaffen
das versprechen der autoindustrie steht
für die iaa gegner ein jedes versprechen
am morgen seien sich klimaaktivisten von
autobahnbrücken ab demonstrieren vor dem
messegelände für ein ende des
verbrechers die konzerne die sich hier
als elektro vorreiter und klimaschützer
präsentieren verkaufen in wahrheit noch
zu 95 prozent diesel und benziner und
der vga der lobbyverband der
autoindustrie bremst damit die
verkehrswende aus und sabotiert
klimaschutz ein wichtiger baustein für
das erreichen der klimaziele ist dabei
der umbau zur e mobilität beschäftigt er
in der autoindustrie fürchten dabei um
ihren arbeitsplatz viele automobilbauer
sind aber optimistisch wir werden keine
menschen entlassen wir sind auf einem
klaren wachstums vaart der sicherstellt
dass wir trotz veränderungen in der
beschäftigungsstruktur bei den
mitarbeitern weiterhin beschäftigung für
alle darstellen können und dadurch wären
sich arbeitsplätze aus der reinen
produktion verlagern in andere bereiche
und damit einhergehend ein sehr viel
größeren schulungsbedarf und um
schulungsbedarf als in der vergangenheit
die zukunft der mobilität bis zum
kommenden wochenende will die iaa in
münchen neue wege aufzeigen
und das dfb team ist auf dem weg zur wm
morgen geht es gegen island nadja und
damit geht die erste bewährungsprobe für
den bundestrainer für hansi flick zu
ende der fest davon ausgeht zum dritten
mal drei punkte für die wm-qualifikation
einzufahren allerdings wird er auf eine
erfahrene offensivkraft aus dortmund
verzichten müssen wegen knieproblemen
konnte marco reus den island trip nicht
mitmachen dafür sind die zuletzt
angeschlagenen harz und großes wieder
mit dabei hansi flick plant an den
erfolgreichen abschluss seiner r
länderspiel reise der dritte sieg im
dritten spiel so das ziel des
bundestrainers der den fokus auf die
eigenen stärken legt und nicht auf die
des gegners
mir ist jetzt erstmal wichtig dass meine
mannschaft auf platz fokussiert ist weil
es einfach auch mit entscheidende ist
dass wir wissen was für eine qualität
wir haben und da ist mir im ersten
moment einfach auch nicht wichtig wer
dann gegenüber ist sie wollen die gute
leistung aus dem armenien spiel
bestätigen und die tabellenführung
verteidigen
für tennisprofi aus karotte sind die us
open zu ende nach der niederlage gegen
den italiener matteo bertini alexander
zverev dagegen hat gegen beide teams
landsmann yannick sinner seine
siegesserie fortgesetzt das
selbstvertrauen des olympiasiegers es
ist in jeder phase zu spüren nach sechs
zu vier in den beiden ersten sätzen wird
es brenzlig ein toller return von cilic
die klare führung im tiebreak und
insgesamt fünf satzbälle kann dieser
nicht nutzen stattdessen 9 zu 7 fürs
wäre dessen erfolgsgeheimnis
ich habe derzeit keine freundin der
liegt stattdessen nachts die
goldmedaille bitter dagegen die umstände
die zum aus von oskar otto führen
unglücklicher sturz auf die rechte hand
wahrscheinlich nichts gebrochen aber im
spiel gegen den italiener barry teenie
hat er dann keine chance mehr verliert
in vier sätzen der kölner hat sich
trotzdem bei diesen us open einen namen
gemacht
deutschlands volleyball männer bleiben
bei der europameisterschaft auf kurs
achtelfinale
die dvv auswahl in weißen trikots feiert
in tallinn gegen lettland den zweiten
sieg im dritten gruppenspiel
nach dem erfolg in 3 1 sätzen wartet am
donnerstag das team der slowakei
das was ich immer noch übertrifft und
die gold mit das wetter bringt morgen
viel sonne und wärme die details hat
gleich als den terni christian sievers
begrüßt sie um viertel vor zehn im heute
journal hier übernimmt morgen jana
pareigis danke für ihr interesse alles
gute ihnen und auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter ja der hohen
luftdruck der schwindet allmählich das
hoch verabschiedet sich ganz langsam
aber es kommt immer noch warme luft aus
dem süden europas zu uns und dieses tief
hier ganz im westen das spielt in den
nächsten tagen eine rolle und es bringt
schauer und gewitter mit aber erst
einmal ist es ruhig vor allem der
kommenden nacht bildet sich in
gewässernähe daneben ansonsten klart es
auf die sterne funkeln vom himmel und
das bei temperaturen von sechs grad an
den alpen und 15 grad zum beispiel ganz
im westen deutschlands morgen dann
verbreitet viel sonnenschein nur ganz im
norden einige harmlose wolken und das
bei höchsten temperaturen von 29 grad im
südwesten deutschlands ansonsten aber
häufig werte über der 25 grad marke am
wenigsten warme ist es an der ostsee mit
23 grad die nächsten tage werden
wechselhafter das tief nähert sich
beziehungsweise die kaltfront des tiefs
gibt schauer und gewitter am donnerstag
im westen bis 28 grad freitag ebenfalls
nun kann auch starkregen dabei sein und
samstag ist es vor allem im osten dann
wechselhafte und nicht meckern zu warm
und damit ein schöner abend